if you don't already think Jenna Ortega
is the best Wednesday Addams get ready
because I'm about to convince you
otherwise when Tim Burton and the rest
of the production team landed on Jenna
it was like a casting light bulb went
off and when we found Jenna it was just
like she was the one it was also clear
that she was truly dedicated to the role
from day one I honestly was so nervous
to do this part because I just want to
do her justice she learned how to
fetchello she learned German and even
dyed her own hair to make it look more
realistic I would walk like Wednesday
and I think that people thought I might
have been kind of crazy